wer in hanoi auf der suche nach der
perfekten instagram kulisse ist wird
hier fündig im herzen der belebten
altstadt sind die alten eisenbahngleise
zu einem hotspot für touristen geworden
und wir haben viele für service posieren
genießen andere ihren kaffee snacks oder
ein bier neben den gleisen doch es ist
vorsicht geboten denn die gleise sind
noch immer in betrieb
das hat einen wirklich seltsame name
überall kommen blumen vom balkon
viele gebäude sind sehr alt und stehen
nah aneinander man sieht menschen die
ich nur ganz normale ernährung den
bahngleisen viel machen wo aber hinzu
ein zug vorbeifährt
das ist verrückt und wenn der zug vorbei
kommt sie einfach ihre sachen und dann
wenn der zug vorbei ist machen sie
weiter als wäre nichts gewesen
die gleise wurden unter französischer
kolonialherrschaft gebaut damals wurde
die eisenbahn benutzt um waren und
menschen durch vietnam zu transportieren
und noch heute ist sie eine gute
verkehrs möglichkeit für reisende die
mit kleinem budget unterwegs sind
[Musik]